la france n'est pas le pays le plus
enclin à accueillir les réfugiés afghans
qui fuient le pouvoir des talibans la
gestion de crise humanitaire est en
demi-teinte puisque emmanuel macron a
dit souhaiter accueillir tout en se
prémunissant des flux migratoires
irréguliers pâtissant du chaos locales
et des lourdeurs administratives
le pont aérien et les rapatriements
n'ont permis jusqu'ici que d'exfiltrer
environ 2000 personnes vers la france
alors qu'une liste de 7000 personnes
menacées a été dressé mais les maires de
france de droite comme de gauche sont
tout de suite monté au créneau certains
contestent la frilosité du président
français face à la perspective de
violations prévisite droits de l'homme
mais d'autres comme christian estrosi
maire de nice s'oppose au contraire à la
venue d'afghans d'autres enfin
tergiverse ainsi robert ménard le maire
de béziers a insisté sur la nécessité de
ne pas laisser rentrer n'importe qui en
europe toutefois et il estime qu'il faut
accueillir les gens mais des dizaines
d'autres mères tendent les bras aux
afghans à bordeaux tours strasbourg
grenoble lyon poitiers besançon ville
gérée par les écologistes les maires ont
immédiatement exprimé leur souhait de
faire vivre le droit d'asile les 28
édiles de la métropole de bordeaux de
droite comme de gauche souhaitent
accueillir des afghans en détresse la
socialiste martine aubry à lille annonce
accueillir plusieurs dizaines de
réfugiés à droite aussi on veut
rejoindre l'effort de solidarité
ainsi le maire les républicains de
saint-etienne gaël perdriau dit vouloir
exercer son devoir humain mais sur la
question migratoire ce sont les services
de l'état et non ceux des villes qui
sont décisionnaires la délivrance de
visas de titre de séjour l'hébergement
de demandeurs d'asile sont des
compétences d'état l'installation de
centres d'hébergement relève aussi de la
responsabilité régalienne alors que
reste-t-il au maire qui n'interviennent
qu'à la fin des procédures et dialogue
avec l'êta jean-philippe gautrais le
maire front de gauche de
fontenay-sous-bois dans le val-de-marne
s'est prononcé pour accueillir et
intégrer l'ensemble des afghans en
danger il nous en parle quand il ya une
crise migratoire eh bien on travaille
l'état travaille en lien avec les
collectivités pour mettre en place des
camps d'urgence ce quand je dis quand ça
peut être des tentes ça peut être des
gymnases sont temporairement pendant un
deux trois mois le temps que les
démarches soient faites administratives
et nous à côté de ça met à disposition
des équipements on peut mettre à
disposition des équipements on peut
mettre à disposition nos politiques
publiques c'est vrai pour l'école c'est
vrai pour le centre de santé il ya
souvent des problématiques de soins à
apporter pour faire des démarches
administratives
et puis mettre en branle notre notre
milieu associatif qui peut accompagner
ces familles pour bien les accueillir et
de manière la plus fraternelle possible
suite à notre communiqué de la semaine
dernière on a un réfugié afghan qui nous
a contactés et d'abord pour nous
remercier de notre démarche d'accueil de
volontaires pour peser sur le
gouvernement français
on est passé de du président de la
république khadir on accueillera
quasiment personne à plus de 2000 et
j'espère a beaucoup plus pour mettre à
l'abri ces personnes en danger c'est une
question d'honneur de mettre à l'abri
des gens qui sont en danger de mort et
qui nous ont par ailleurs aidé c'est
n'est que légitime que nous fassions
honneur à la france de les accueillir le
plus dignement possible si les maires
sont bienveillants et volontaire il
reste encore à exfiltrer ces personnes
en danger de kaboul car le temps est
compté et le numéro de téléphone de la
cellule de crise du ministère des
affaires étrangères est saturé les
maires devront donc sûrement refermer
leurs bras sur du vide